5 55 on your monday morning so after a  drive any crazy story last month with a  viewer complaint about people not using  their headlights  another viewer wendy has responded she  writes  when i turn on the ignition i turn  on my headlights it's automatic good for  you wendy but wendy's also got something  else on her mind  she wrote in aren't people getting sick  and tired of streets and highways being  used for race tracks  she says driving down sunset a car  zoomed past her 65-35  after crossing boulder highway she  floored it was gone under flash about  80 in a 45. can someone explain where  the traffic cops are  well wendy we'll bring this up in one of  our mornings with metro conversations  with the leadership team of the police  department stay tuned and  thanks again for taking the time to  write in buckle up drive carefully  please put down that phone  if there is something driving you crazy  email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com